hey
here we are once again yeah the hell day
is it it's tuesday
yeah hopefully the guy next door is done
trimming his hedges because
that [ __ ] was really [ __ ] loud in
here and i was just
until like two minutes ago and i'm like
dude please stop with the bush
how's volume is volume good everybody
yeah i mean it should be
i've been recording on this [ __ ] all day
so we recorded
some movie review we recorded a book
review we did all kinds of [ __ ]
okay so uh do you want to talk about the
movie first or do you want to talk about
the
the creepy [ __ ] first we'll talk about
the movie first
yeah let's talk about the movie yeah
some poultry guys should happen we'll
talk about it
yeah well that'll be like the teaser
i'll let her tell the story yeah well
we'll talk about the baby first like i
said
all right so this is another one uh
that we found on toby uh this is a 2020
movie called scare me
now what i did not know when i chose
this movie
but found out when i was going to
research this [ __ ] earlier today was
that
there is yet another indie movie that
came out in 2020
that was called scare me and it was like
the the premise of it was very similar
except it was like a cabin instead of a
campground
like you know with telling scary stories
and [ __ ] the weird thing about it is
that when i was looking for
so most of the reviews that i found of
it were of the other movie and not this
one
the weird thing though is that i found
some artwork that had the poster
from this movie it was like a dvd cover
but the pictures on the back of the dvd
cover were from the other ones
yeah so there's evidence some confusion
so i guess there's some confusion now
the other one i haven't seen like
apparently it premiered at sundance and
i've
you know i skimmed through some of the
reviews and apparently not too bad
this one um this one is like
ultra low budget i mean not like ouija
shark
level but maybe like a cheap porno level
yeah budget kinda and it does kind of
come across like not a cheap porno
no yeah cheaper has no budget girl
all right you just do that in the
parking lot with a lot lizard
you know in your phone it's realistic no
it had
it had it had a bigger budget than that
it's just uh
it's a homemade movie you could tell but
it had some skill to it had good
practical effects acting was good
boobies were good
there was a lot of boobies yeah the boob
man boob man made made the movie
he was yeah tom was very happy i was
going like as a boot man
starts off with goth girls with big
boobs [ __ ]
dressed up like witches sacrificing some
dude cutting his eyeballs out it looked
it looked pretty good yeah they actually
the practical effects in this were
actually very good i didn't think that
acting was all that great
it's like it was kind of amateurish yeah
they're just making a movie
but yeah so basically what the premise
of the story now
okay it didn't say in the description
that it was an anthology movie but i
assumed when i read this when i read the
description of it
that it was going to be an anthology
movie because basically the
the rundown was there's a bunch of
college kids they go
to like a ghost story contest like out
at a campground and they're trying and
then it like turns into a real like they
turn up
in their own horror stories or something
so i assumed it was an anthology movie
and it kind of is yeah but it's
structured very
weirdly it's not structured like a
standard anthology
right there's no wrap around there's
nothing really like that the movie just
i don't know it's hard to follow i
didn't care though
[Laughter]
it was it was hilarious it had some
funny parts it had some funny parts it
was like it's like dumb
yeah but the gore was good there was
lots lots of titties
yeah they weren't taking it seriously so
i didn't really take it that way it
didn't make a lot of sense
no i don't think but we'll see they were
making it up as they were going i think
that the wrap around well i mean the
wrap around was supposed to be
the story with all the college kids
telling each other the other stories
which you don't find out until the very
end that the title of that is called
millennial massacre okay but in between
so like almost two-thirds of the movie
is that
yeah so that's why for a long time
because they open
with the titty witches titty witches
like
that that's my new riot girl band it's a
throwback 90s riot girl band it's called
the titty
but yeah so you're all at least c cup
which tom always appreciates because
he's like whenever there's a horror
movie and there's like a girl gets her
top off in there and he's like
very big that's like what i mean she's
kind of flat
but yeah so these ones these ones all
had a healthy they're going you're dee's
judgmental
yeah she's in a movie
they're not supposed to represent
reality you know i mean she's supposed
to represent you know the cutting edge
cutting edge of
technology
yeah so that's so it opens with this
like there's just a guy in a waiting
room
and you assume that he's going in there
for like some fetish [ __ ] and like
there's witches and titties and whatever
and then they end up cutting his
eyeballs out and then that ends up being
the eyes wide shut a disaster that's
what i said because somebody had like a
mask
which was kind of a cool like bird mask
i said oh they're gonna eyes wide shut
his ass
but yeah so so that happens and you're
just like oh okay fair enough
and then that ends up being a story and
then they go right into
the supposed wrap around but like i said
the wraparound
is pretty much the entire movie so
so you have like all these people like
interacting they're going to the
campsite they're
putting up the tents they're interacting
with this clearly very sketchy park
ranger named coop
um who's kind of helpful at first but
you know he's evil because that's just
how the [ __ ] works
and you know so you have that and then
finally finally
they sit down the fire and they start
telling each other stories
so so there's like short stories in
there but i feel like
one criticism of this movie like i said
this is not great art it's not
even that good of a movie but it was
fairly entertaining
one criticism yeah it was free um one
criticism
it's too long it is too long it was an
hour and 47 minutes it didn't need to be
that long i feel like they could have
just i mean i liked the
short story segments like um you know
the one with the
the late the podcaster and the guy that
comes to the door that's been shot
and then there was actually i think the
best one was uh eternal slumber i think
it was called
with like the the guy whose dog runs
into the neighbor's yard and then like
he looks in the window and sees the guy
and
like banging a [ __ ] and then yeah that
one was actually pretty good
i liked that one yeah but it's like so
those are like only a few minutes long
so i feel like those could have been
taken out
and then like the part of them just at
the campground
should have just been the whole movie
even though it wouldn't have been that
good a movie because i think that the
short story is kind of elevated it's
almost kind of like this movie
was a group effort it's almost like like
there were more than one team
it's like it might have been four or
five different teams making movies
i don't think it was though which is
weird it seemed very uneven
some of it yeah real good quality the
way it looked so it didn't look that
good
but and some of it was kind of creative
and
other parts that were just kind of
meandering it's like they shot a lot of
material and they were [ __ ] dedicated
to use everything to use all of it and
they wanted to find
some way to put it all together yeah i
think
this movie could have really been saved
and edit a real tight edit
and a better flow would have made this
movie even more more fun yeah i mean
it's it's fine
it's like entertaining all over the
place but it was a story so it's it's
it's difficult to get that
to go in at an even pace yeah just
because you have
too many stories well it's well it's not
even so much that it's
just that the the wrap around story is
almost the whole movie
yeah and then they just like throw in
another short story it's like oh now
he's gonna tell his story and like
i don't know it's just really weird it
didn't need a wraparound story or
something they could have just made some
more short films
and then just they could have taken the
wrap around part
and made that way shorter and then just
put it at like the beginning and the end
and maybe little snippets in the middle
and then added some a couple more short
films
and then just made it a more standard
anthology because for some
other than like the titty witches at the
beginning and then the whole
college kids with in the campground and
everything i was like wait
i thought this was an anthology maybe
it's not an anthology but then it wasn't
it was
like what was what was that at the
beginning yeah it's like who were these
people that was never addressed again
and then there were some times where it
looked like the way i remembered it
it seemed like some of the people at the
damn
campground in the wraparound story had
killed each other
yeah i was confused because some of the
actors and actresses
they looked alike looked alike yeah so
some of the ones that were like in the
stories i'm like wait
is this the person that was like in the
rapper because what the [ __ ] is going on
like i wasn't really sure like what are
they telling
are they telling the story of something
that they did and that's why they're in
the story
or they're putting themselves in the
story yeah that wasn't super
real clear what had happened each one
telling some wild ass tale
that really was they're not important
the only one that kind of stuck out
was the guy [ __ ] looking through the
other dude's window and seeing him
[ __ ]
railing that dude in the vote in the
booty man [ __ ] the game all
get out and he's just [ __ ] riding
without mercy
and and they would that's another thing
this movie has no regard for any kind of
pc [ __ ] which i'm gonna give it [ __ ]
i'm gonna give it like an extra extra
thumbs up for that
because it probably wouldn't allow you
to make a movie make that anymore
nowaday i don't know
well they did make it doesn't make this
from this year but a big stu
a big hollywood studio wouldn't allow
that i don't think um
then the dude goes in there to try to
save the gift it's really the the
highlight of the movie
i think that was kind of the best story
some of the other stories were good too
but i think that was kind of the best
goes in to save the game there's always
dead cats everywhere he was looking for
the cats
because there was like rewards for the
cats or no he wasn't looking for the
cats he saw that people were looking for
the kids yeah there was like posters
he was looking for his dog because his
dog ran into the neighbor's
yard yeah and it turns out [ __ ]
freaky
freaky [ __ ] rapist mr rapist was
feeding the [ __ ] all these [ __ ] cats
and dogs they're all torn up
so he goes in there and try to save him
i'm not spoiling anything okay
so he goes in there and [ __ ] cut the
gift loose you know what i mean it's
gonna be all right man the kemp turns on
him attacks him
turns out it's a [ __ ] zombie yeah he's a
camp zombie
yeah so that so that dude was like super
freaky
yeah and then i don't remember what
happened after that i don't think i
don't think anything happened that went
to another story
and i think that was the end of this
yeah well
another thing too and i'm not entirely
sure about this but i was watching
another review of this
earlier i think it was a happy wax tv i
watched some of his reviews sometimes
he's canadian
and um he said that the one story that
the stoner guy
tells about uh the babysitter and like
the little kid that's like i think it's
called demonic presence but presents
like christmas presents rather than
presents like a presence in the room
so well that thing where that happened
was like
somebody goes up to the like the dad
goes up to the room and the little kid
is in the bed going there's a monster in
my closet and then the dad goes in the
closet but the
kid is in there and then he turns around
and then like the kid on the bed is like
a demon he's like
like with white eyes and stuff now the
guy the other guy on happy wax tv
he said that that was had been the
premise of a short film like a very
quite a famous short film that went
around on youtube and he
said that he wasn't sure that the
filmmakers of this film
credited um you know that person
for kind of stealing their story idea
because that's apparently like a pretty
famous
and now that i'm like thinking about it
i was like yeah i do think i kind of
remember maybe seeing that or seeing
something with that
concept or that idea um so he was
pointing that out i don't know if it's
true or not
but i don't know if they like stole an
idea and they were just like because
they did almost acknowledge it because
the stoner is like telling the story
and then the [ __ ] park ranger keeps
interrupting him like oh this is what's
gonna happen and that's what's gonna
happen so it's almost like they were
acknowledging that they had stolen the
idea from somewhere else
yeah but they didn't really like credit
maybe they did in the credits i didn't
notice
what was funny is like just how uneven
certain parts of it were like the tit
it opens up with the titty which is in
the brothel i guess is what it was or
whatever
it's never really explained he's paying
to get some bdsm action you know
and uh that's really one of the best
parts highlights of the movie because
you know nice boobs because boobs they
all looked good
and um but it was shot pretty crappy it
was like it was done on your [ __ ]
phone
yeah um it didn't you know there wasn't
any kind of filters or [ __ ] the light
work wasn't you know anything special
although i remember the score actually
being okay
yeah i think it was actually the score
kind of like a carpenter type score
and had a little bit of new retro waves
yeah they were doing [ __ ]
and then um later on
in the other stories like when they
would tell a story there would actually
be like titles would appear
and like effects yeah and and the way it
was shot was a lot better so it was very
uneven
so the quality kind of got better at
certain certain parts
but throughout all of it the um the gore
special effects were actually uh pretty
good which is surprising
the makeup was pretty good i think the
practical effects were the highlight of
this yeah they spent money on them
i mean the eyeballs getting pulled out
like somebody got their
like thing through their chest and the
heart and everything it's like so i feel
like when they did gore effects they
looked really good
it's almost kind of like a couple
different production crews were working
or they were just making stories as they
went and decided to tie them together to
tie them all together
something like that it was like this was
originally more than one movie i think
maybe it was
it's like been a couple of movies that
they combined it's credited to one
person i think his name is mark stevens
like written and directed so i don't
know if these were just
maybe this was a way of maybe he had
made some short films earlier
and his way of using them and then he
had made like this other film and it
wasn't long enough so he thought maybe
i'll make it into an anthology and kind
of put him together
which you know that's that's an
admirable uh
you know pursuit but like i said if
you're gonna make an anthology
i kind of feel like it should be you
gotta have a tight edit paste
better like like i said it seemed kind
of long and it seemed like the wrap
around was pretty much the entire movie
was just oh by the way i'm gonna tell
this story for five or ten minutes
yeah and then they go back to the wrap
around again and there's a lot of
[ __ ] like just banter between
yeah i could have done without that yeah
there's just a lot of just like
regular hey let's have some dialogue
here let's do some quentin tarantino
dialogue and we'll just talk about some
you know doritos
or some [ __ ] yeah quentin would do you
know
yeah although i just have some girl
talking about bellies and pot bellies
and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] about your pot belly man i
remember that
yeah pulp fiction i don't know why but
that is one of the
most memorable scenes in that book yeah
the only time when there was like
useless banter
really that was pretty good at quinn
tarantino was like
between [ __ ] john travolta and uh oh
[ __ ] yes
uh what's his name i don't even want to
say samuel adams
that's the beer that's the beer yeah
jackson yeah samuel jackson you know
they're talking about stupid [ __ ] you
know quarter pounders and [ __ ] some of
that was kind of funny but
well i think if you're gonna do i don't
and and i'm not like averse to
having characters banter in movies but a
lot of that has to do with your actors
and your screenwriter yeah um because
sometimes
you can pull it off sometimes not so
much i mean i know
particularly in horror movies you do
like want to get a sense of the
characters you do want to
like at least get people to care a
little bit about them so you don't want
them to get killed but it's like
this one i don't even i don't even
remember
any of the characters names other than
the park ranger guy
yeah and i just remember that because i
remember like the others was saying that
but i don't remember any of the other
characters names
talk about karen tarantino though
tarantino can do banter between guys he
couldn't write female dialogue i think
that's what it is a lot of guys have
problems i think that's the problem
um you know and and some male novelists
have a problem with that too
not too badly like but i've read a
couple books
like horror books that were written by
men where they were they had a female
character like what she was thinking and
i'm like
okay you don't have any idea what the
[ __ ] going on in there
but yeah it's like this is free on to be
um
if it sounds like something you'd be
into like i said don't i'm not
recommending it because you know don't
come at me or anything
it's not great it's kind of cheap um
but the gore effects are good it's got
some funny [ __ ] in it it's kind of
entertaining like i didn't get bored or
anything like i didn't be like oh [ __ ]
this turn it off
like i have had a couple of movies like
that that were just like really cheap
that i couldn't sit through
um so it didn't like ever just piss me
off or make me want to turn it off or
anything
but it could have been trimmed down to
like 88 minutes
yeah well the material that they had
wasn't bad it's just that it wasn't
it wasn't really edited yeah it wasn't
like put together
real well like in a cohesive just very
packaged it was
playing very fast and loose with [ __ ]
storytelling and
um they were just using the footage they
had if you ask me
that's kind of what it seems like and
maybe i don't know if that's the case
but
that is kind of how how it came across
that they were like hey we have all
these short films and
we have this other footage so let's like
kind of throw it all together tighter
screenplay and a [ __ ] better edit
you know this guy could have you know
potential
yeah you know you know he was his
influences were good
yeah i mean there were little spots
there that were like oh yeah this is
pretty you know i could watch a whole
movie of that but
i guess for budgetary reasons it
couldn't you couldn't really you know
make a movie about the [ __ ] guy plus you
know that is a
tarantino homage yeah it was big time
and there was also the thing where there
were some guys that
were keeping a zombie girl down in a
building and were
uh having sex with it that's right and
people thought that that they were
raping some captive girl it was a zombie
the whole time
yeah remember that one wasn't that was
that uh that
[ __ ] was that that one long time ago
was it strange land
no maybe no no i can't remember what it
was
uh was that that was the one that d
snyder directed right no no not that one
oh okay
i don't think it was that one i know
what you're talking about this was like
2010 maybe
oh okay so it's fairly recent 2010 2009
i think i remember that premise but i'm
sure i probably saw it but yeah
part of the movie you know they got it
wrapped up in plastic and chained up in
an abandoned building
yeah and i think what you're talking
about and the way it's filmed you think
they got some girl captive down there
but it was a hot girl but it was a hot
zombie
hot dog yeah she's i hot they washed her
up or something well you know
well i showed her they showed her they
they they showed her figure you know
what i mean she looked like a normal
girl but she was a zombie
yeah they said that's why i remembered
haven't seen him [ __ ] forever well
now we have to like lift that [ __ ] up i
didn't like it though
yeah yeah like half halfway you know i'm
watching the first half of it and i'm
just like oh
come on you know this shit's over the
top you know like
because it takes a long time to find out
what what is actually going on
right and they had agreed not to tell
anybody that they had this zombie and
they were going down there screwing it
well and now that you know it's a zombie
it's like that first half of the movie
is gonna seem like interminable because
you're like i know it's a zombie get out
of
it yeah somebody in the audience might
know it
oracle says there's such a thing as a
hot zombie there is a
zombie erotica so apparently some people
think so i'm not one of those people
um all right but yeah so it's on to be
if you want to watch it like i said
don't come at me if you don't like it
it's not a fantastic movie but
it was an okay time waster just could
have been a lot shorter all right so
let's talk about the paranormal activity
yeah not the movie
the actual paragraph yeah activity
change tell a story from the first okay
so
she's people mark morocco she saw more
than i did actually as
as you guys know i mean because most of
you have been with the show for a long
time
and uh you know tom had the poltergeist
[ __ ] happen when he was a kid
and then we had some poltergeist
activity happen here
probably a few years ago yeah but it
hasn't really happened before that now
the weird thing
is that well we had the tv stuff that
would happen yeah
but the weird thing is we hadn't thought
about that for a while
now we were watching uh a movie about
telekinesis which is one of the ones
that we're gonna be
that's reviewing at the end of the week
for the movie retrospective yeah
so we were thinking about that and tom
said something while we were watching it
to the effect he was like oh man
remember
when the tv in the living room would
come on by itself all the time
and then we remembered that the tv in
the living room because we bought a new
tv to go in the living room and then we
took the one in the living room and put
it in our bedroom
yeah so we're like oh well that's you
know bigger
yeah because it's bigger so we were kind
of like well
that you know that was the tv that used
to come on by itself all the time it
hasn't done that for a really long time
yeah i just thought that
says that's awful weird yeah that was
awful weird that that happened
and then guess what happened last night
what time was it when the first one
happened because i was almost falling
asleep so it was probably like 10 or 10
30.
no it was more like that it was like 11
o'clock oh okay was it because i was
like
i was half asleep went to bed early
about 10. yeah i was watching hoarders
and then i was like i had my headphones
i can't watch this anywhere i had my
headphones on and
i saw blue light and opened my eyes and
the damn television had turned on again
yeah
and i just mentioned that what was it
the day before yeah i think it was the
day before
or maybe it was that friday night i
think it was friday night we were
talking about that because we were
talking about when we were watching the
movie because you said oh man that
that [ __ ] hadn't happened and i said
yeah that tv hasn't come on in a long
time and he said oh this is the same tv
because we moved it remember yeah so
jenny was
a little bit of sleeping so i was like
half asleep and i said jenny that tv
turned out and i was like yeah
oh man that's weird and and i would
and uh at the foot of the bed there's
one what do you call that thing that we
have the foot there i don't know it's
like a
it's not like a footstool but it's like
a launch that opens up you can sit on it
it's like a foot locker but it's like a
couch like a seat yeah then it opens and
you can push it and it's
like we have one of those at the foot of
the bed that you can sit on and watch tv
well that's where the remote was so
there's no way we hit that remote
and pookie wasn't in the room either so
she didn't step on it and another thing
too is that
when we turn the tv on we turn it on
through the xbox
yeah no yeah yeah yeah well you turn the
xbox on and then you turn the tv on
right yeah
this came up i don't know about the
first time but the second and third time
it came on through well you're getting
ahead of yourself yeah
so then the tv okay that tv turned on at
about 11 o'clock
i said jenny did that tv turned back on
and she's like oh no and i went yeah
because we were just talking about it i
think that's yeah yeah
so i went down got the remote off that
thing and turned it off i went back to
listen to my headphones
and fell asleep and i didn't know it but
what time was it okay so i then i woke
up
at 5 00 a.m because i had to go to the
bathroom so then i get back in bed and
i'm just laying there and i was like oh
well i guess i'm not going back to sleep
tonight because that's what the [ __ ]
happens when you get old
5 30 he was still asleep
and he kind of groaned and sleep like
and he like rolled over and kind of like
smacked me like that
and the tv came on again yeah and it's
bright like when it comes on it's like
bright
white blue yeah and i was like god damn
it and then like i said and he didn't
wake up
so this was 5 30 in the morning so i sit
up and i'm like like
feeling like where the [ __ ] is the
remote because i didn't know where the
[ __ ] remote was
and then i noticed that not only was the
tv on the cable was on the directv cable
box was on
and the sound bar was on yeah and that's
a different remote
control that's not on the same remote
control yeah and this
yeah so she turns all that [ __ ] off i
ain't nothing about it yeah he was still
asleep at that point
and then what six o'clock it came back
on it was 6 30 or 6
20. it was 6 20. so it came it came on
and and i woke up for that one you woke
up for that one because
i woke you told me that i turned it on
you said
see i was growling and it turned on yeah
you were in your sleep
because the you did the same thing again
you had done the same thing at 5
30 like you were asleep but you were
kind of like and you rolled over and you
kind of like you didn't hit
me but your arm kind of went flop like
that yeah and then it came on like
immediately
yeah and then you did the same thing at
6 20. you were like mom
well like that and then it came on again
and i so then i woke you up i was like
tom
the tv came on again yeah and then and
the same thing it was like [ __ ]
i don't know it was like really really
weird yeah i i knew and when you when
you woke me up that
the third time that it came on when you
woke me up i was dreaming
that's what i know what i was dreaming
about it's a [ __ ] danvest thing
i had a dream that me and a couple of
other guys were in some kind of workshop
somewhere
and i was we were building a rifle
it was a futuristic rifle looked like
something out of that thing from blood
machines
like that and i was watching in slow
motion
a burning propellant charge force a
bullet down a barrel
and i was going as i was watching it go
down the barrel
and that's when it worked and the reason
why
and what was weird about the rifle that
we were building is it wasn't metallic
cartridge case
rifle we were using hypergolic fuel
and injecting it into a chamber and then
it would self-ignite
and it would thrust like a damn rocket
to push the [ __ ]
bullet out the barrel it was a test
rifle it wasn't a real rifle it was one
you're just
i saw it in my mind this is a very
specific dream you were yeah well i'm
you know
you know firearms and firearm technology
ever [ __ ]
there was no ignition system or anything
it was just
it had a magazine that was feeding
projectiles up out of a magazine
into a chamber that would seal itself
off it was kind of
rotary yeah and it was injecting
hypergolic gas in there to [ __ ]
explode and it was thrusted out like a
rocket and i was seeing it happen in
slow motion
and that's what happened when the tv
turned on see it's you
that's what i'm saying i was watching it
thrust down that damn barrel
this burning plasma behind it in real
slow motion and i kind of felt like
i wasn't seeing it happening in slow
motion like through a computer screen
it was like i was like i had slowed
time down and could see through the
matter like i was almost kind of like in
a
like matrix bullet time kind of well the
rifle yeah like the matrix
something the rifle was transparent i
could see right through it
neat you know what i mean through the
barrel and everything and see what was
happening
in there so you made the tv come on
somehow thinking about that caused it to
turn the tv on
that's i wonder what you're dreaming the
first time i don't like like at 5 30.
i don't know so it's not it's not any
kind of violent thoughts or
or thoughts of any kind of fears but
it's funny that it started it when i
when i wondered why it didn't you know
the way it didn't happen again
it'll happen again now because as soon
as you start talking well yeah because
as soon as you talk about it because
literally when because that's why i
wasn't even like that
bothered like when you told me the first
time because i was like half asleep and
i was like oh man whatever i was like
you know what i mean because i was tired
and also
i was like well that figures because we
were talking about it
yeah and we're talking about oh remember
when the tv used to come on all the time
because i used to that tv used to be in
the living room
and i would go out in the in the kitchen
in the morning to make coffee and i'd be
like god damn it that [ __ ] tv is on
again and nobody used that tv in the
living room we never watched it
it was hardly ever on and it doesn't
come on anymore and it doesn't come on
anymore and it happened
it had in a year long yeah when did we
buy that other one
i can't remember it might be about a
year it was probably like a year ago so
it hadn't turned on and it hadn't turned
on by itself since we'd moved it into
our bedroom
and actually when it was in the living
room it had been like probably another
year before that since it's
like turned on by itself the tv
[ __ ] episode thing that went on for
about what
three months off and on yeah
there was one run in there of like a
month or two or two where it would be on
like every day almost every day like
maybe every other day like in the
morning the tv was on
and it was on it was just on a
screensaver yeah and it was really weird
and it's just like it got to a point
where
i mean it's creepy we thought maybe
there was some kind of error
yeah we asked the like one time when the
cable guy came or the tv repair
guy came we asked him about it and he
looked at us like we were
yeah like we had underwear and we now
move that into our bedroom and i meant
the reason why i mentioned is we saw
that movie yeah
and afterwards i said i had a feeling
that like like it was watching me again
yeah and then i thought of that tv yeah
and i said it's funny how that tv hasn't
turned on anymore
and then and it turned on in a couple
days it started coming on
it better not tell it to stop because
it's like if that keeps waking me up
i'm gonna get really really annoyed when
it first came on last night
you know at 11 i had that weird feeling
the presence but i i
kind of i shook it off yeah felt like it
was watching me
yeah i didn't feel like that i just felt
like god [ __ ] damn it now i can't
sleep because it's suck it's [ __ ]
bright and then i have to like go
feel it around for the [ __ ] remote
because i don't know what's happening
when i'm falling asleep or waking up
well yeah because you're not you're like
in a hypnagogic or that's about the time
i talk in my sleep too isn't it
yeah usually but i just thought it was
so funny that like
it it was exactly like when you were
like
like when you rolled over like flopped
over yeah and then dick
that blue light came on yeah it's not
the conscious mind it's some kind of an
unconscious
and i was like [ __ ] and there's no way
to understand how it
how it does it i mean you know we just
we just recently got pookie to stop
jumping on our
stomachs in the middle of the night she
still does it every now and then but
um and now your poltergeist is going to
be turning the tv on in the middle of
the night waking me up because like i
said it's super super bright
but i don't know we'll see what happens
is i mean as long as it's not it's just
the tv and it's not like
[ __ ] falling off breaking and all that
kind of crap
or the [ __ ] doorbell yes it did that
before and the garage door opened we
don't want
that to [ __ ] happen like the big
garage door opened
that kind of sucked and oh and the
patio door opened too with the deadbolt
still in it
yeah that just happened one time yeah it
didn't happen once but still it's like
you don't want that it's like in case
somebody's wandered it's not like
anybody's wandering around in our
backyard
usually but yeah as soon as they're
saying that this being's watching me
it's not it's it's not
it's not an external being it's it's the
unconscious mind
that's why i'm not really scared of it
because i think it's him
yeah it was it's the it was a lot worse
when i uh
was 12 with 13. going through that
[ __ ] puberty phase it was a lot worse
you know it was throwing objects and
people saw it re read mouth mountain
poultry guys
yeah there's all kind of crazy [ __ ]
happening in there yeah so it's like if
it's just the tv popping on
yeah that's that's irritating but you
know the last time it's done anything
really big was when
um dimitri and
dimitri and jen were over and when it
was with the remote control oh and
and the horse
it tore down the molding off the top of
the kitchen i was in here for that i was
at work
yeah that happened when my back was
turned and it sounded like a damn
gunshot
wow really loud my [ __ ] jumped out of
my skin
yeah it wrenched off the molding pulled
it out by the
on the cabinet pulled it out by the
[ __ ] nails and it had
it did it quick like a you know split
second boom
and it what was weird is those [ __ ]
little nails on the end of that molding
were all crooked like damn
[ __ ] spaghetti and it didn't break
that
it didn't break the wooden molding which
was [ __ ] thick it was like bent out
wasn't it pulled it out by the
that big long rod of molding was about
six feet long
yeah and it's just you know an inch wide
just that flimsy [ __ ] you could snap it
with your hand
it pulled it out it had three nails on
either side at least and i think a
couple in the center
it pulled it out in a single [ __ ]
stroke without breaking that wood
but it had those nails bent yeah i had
to straighten them all out with a hammer
and tack it all back into place
and it threw the two of the yeah shoes
at the same time off the top it must
have threw them out about seven
feet well yeah because like the ground
the same time
that the [ __ ] molding popped off it
was just one event
and there were more there are more
little ceramic statues up there other
than those two but those were the only
two that moved and it was weird they
didn't break
i thought one of them did just a little
chip but you know you would think that
they would have
they were wood you think they would have
shattered the weird thing about it is
that they were thrown
when they came off of there they came
out onto they fell onto the floor
yeah they were into an arc yeah like
that because if they'd fallen straight
down they would have fallen right on the
stove
yeah they couldn't fall straight down
there was no straight down remember yeah
how could they fall straight down yeah
they were a foot into the in
on top of those things right i'm just
saying that even even if somebody said
oh they got knocked off to the edge and
then fell like that
they would have fallen onto the stove
top but they didn't yeah they felt like
way out on the floor like they got
thrown
yeah so that was pretty weird yeah it
was weird so yeah
it's been about three years huh yeah
that was a while back
well it might have been longer than that
because um
it was longer than that because i was
still working i was still working at the
print shop
and i left there in the summer of 2016.
so it must have happened before you
didn't see that one no i was at work
that day yeah yeah and then you told me
about it later yeah
that's a [ __ ] trip but yeah so we'll
report back if the tv keeps coming on
maybe you're really annoyed if that
[ __ ] tv keeps coming on every couple
of hours
it's uh rspk recurrent spontaneous i
know
but it's like because i can't think of
any other reason
like why it would just come on like i
said it's not like pookie is stepping on
the thing
because she wasn't i don't think she was
in the room and even if she was
it's like you would have to you would
have to sit on the
on the remote for the tv and the remote
for
the sound bar at least because those two
are separate right
so so i don't even even if she was like
[ __ ] with them which i don't think
she was
could you hear her well what's the
chances of that happening three times at
one point that's what i'm saying
no i didn't hear her in the room it was
just
a slight resurgence of it yeah the mind
when we think of ourselves we think of
one person but really your mind is a
[ __ ]
a conversation of several different
[ __ ]
hemispheres all talking to each other
trying to come to a conclusion
most of them are in your unconscious
this has all been proven because they've
cut people's brains apart
yeah and they you don't operate the same
so those inner voices in your head
they're all you they're just different
aspects of you
well one of those back in there somehow
can violate space time
in a weird [ __ ] quantum physics kind
of way
oh what's his name was talking about it
yeah little uh stuart ameroff yeah
he was an anesthesiologist if you want
to know more about it and talk to stuart
stuart ameroff
but uh i saw a poltergeist activity
wrote about it in math mountain poultry
guys she wrote
she she wrote my story down and lois and
red were there you know my cousin and
i i saw not not as not as intense to say
like uh what was reported from uh
enfield poltergeist but close didn't
last as long
yeah it lasted a couple weeks but a lot
of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] happened
a lot of [ __ ] happened i thought it was
some kind of a ghost we all did for a
while but then
in that final few hours i realized it
wasn't a ghost at all
it's just it's the unconscious mind
doing it it's psychokinesis
ken asked if you've ever tried to
purposely do it yeah that's how i
stopped it
yeah when i was we talked about that in
the in the book
i tried to i tried to actually do it by
will and then it stopped the entire
because when you stop the entire event
because
when you try to do it by your own will
what it is is you've now taken ownership
of the phenomenon
and the phenomenon only worked when you
were attributing it to an outside force
that's all the only way i can explain it
it somehow resolves some kind of in
conflict in between certain hemispheres
of your brain
that's they're like oh it's me and then
it just goes away then it went away yeah
yeah
but the weird thing is like now even
though you're pretty sure it's you it's
still
it still does it every now and then but
it usually does it when you're sleeping
or when you're like spaced out or when
you're like
like when you're zoned out like playing
a video game or when you're asleep or
something
when i'm in altered states of
consciousness it'll kind of slip out
every now and then
yeah but it's it doesn't seem to be
useful it's because
it's leak yeah you would think you could
use it for combat or use it like what
the jedi use it for but it doesn't
really work that way it doesn't
maybe species that are evolved more
highly than human beings maybe on other
planets can do it but
not us i don't think i know see wouldn't
that be like an awesome superpower but
oh well
it would you'd end up being like
something out of forbidden planet
everybody kill each other with it
they would probably so so it's probably
better than right wheeled it
something it's just it's
like scanners you'd make everyone's head
explode it's a natural phenomenon
we don't really understand nature that
well it has something
that has something to do with uh physics
space time reality isn't as real as we
think it is it's something like that
or reality is what you perceive it to be
in a certain way not all times but under
certain circumstances
yeah it's like those heisenberg
uncertainty principles you know
how can an object be in two places at
once spooky action at a distance that
weird kind of [ __ ]
it's something happening in a higher
dimensional plane yeah i think
it's it's in a a part of us must exist
in a direction we can't point to but
that direction does exist
and over and because you're in that
that direction or that in that higher
dimension you're in some way touching
these objects
somehow you just don't realize it
beth said stuff always happened with her
mom when she was overly stressed
yeah yeah yeah me with me it's more like
when i'm kind of
now on something else
yeah like it happened weird [ __ ]
happened when i was playing the mad max
video game and i was just totally
into it i had a damn e-liquid measuring
cup like something you take nyquil out
of
it i saw it out of the corner of my eye
it was weird you know i felt like some
kind of weird wind
a wind that didn't that i didn't feel
but it looked like a wind blowing
it just looked like it like a
disturbance
and it's where the uh was on a bookcase
that had all the
blu-rays in it and i know i left that
little cup
like on the second shelf from the top
and i saw it just streak straight down
and hit the bottom shelf and hit go hit
on its bottom perfectly and just rattled
and i passed paused and looked and it
was on the bottom shelf i saw it out of
the corner of my eye streaked straight
down
well it didn't come out through the
shelf it went right through them
yeah i just suddenly decided that the
shelves weren't there anymore yeah inner
penetration of matter you saw it all the
time and
when when the phenomena first happened
back in mountain mountain
objects would appear in a room we were
standing outside the door waiting for
them to appear and we'd open up there'd
be something in there from another room
you know towels and pillows and [ __ ]
from another room or
pieces of clothing it'd lay things out
make smiley faces on the bed and [ __ ]
with [ __ ] towels and throw things at
you
um lois and red had the damn they were
sitting there and
pillows flew up over their head and the
[ __ ] bedspread flew off the bed
wrapped around their legs
lois said she felt it touch her said it
felt like a damn cold
like a snake with a hand on it go up her
leg and around her waist
and then just vanish it was just an
invisible
an invisible force she could kind of
feel it
don't do that to me okay weird huh she
said it felt like it came up out of the
ground and snaked up around her leg
and around her waist and vanished in
about a second and a half
yikes yeah she couldn't see anything she
just felt it i mean some of the stuff
like i said the tv
coming on that kind of stuff that
doesn't scare me because it's like it's
happened so often
and like i said i know it's you so it's
like it's just the tv it's not that big
a deal
but even if i knew it was you if it was
something like
um you like somehow manifested like a
creepy shadow person
or like it threw a brick at me from
another room or something like that then
that would probably scare me
well at the strongest that it ever was
the only thing that ever manifested was
that damn
kind of like a blue like a blue field
yeah a mist you could see it only from a
distance
it was slightly luminescent but it
seemed to be look just like one of those
things when you rub your eyes you see
colors in there
like just spot just like that but and
you could try to focus directly on it
you would you had a problem seeing it
but if you
looked a little bit to the side you'd
see it yeah i mean
kind of like now you have problems
focusing in on an object in a darkened
room
but if you scan your relax your eyes and
scan them you can see it yeah everybody
could do that you'd see it like a blue
field
and then another one that happened was
kind of like a
a weird feeling of being watched up from
a corner of a [ __ ] ceiling
and you could see kind of like a round
bluish
sphere was kind of bluish and clear
and it looked like it it was unstable if
you tried to [ __ ]
if you tried to focus directly on it it
would vanish like your eyes were
focusing through it you know what i mean
yeah but if you kind of look to the side
you'd see it like a little
round ball probably like the size of a
size of a softball maybe no
maybe like a like a soccer ball about
like that big yeah
and it look it just you had feeling like
you were being watched
you know from that ball yeah and then me
and reddit sit there looking at it like
you see it
yeah i see it you know what is that
thing and red's like that's it that's
that's it that's let's do it that's the
thing
yeah and then like it'd be like it's
gone and you never like because it
seemed to
like fade away he's like yeah it's gone
now you know just [ __ ] like that and
then you see it again later
there he is again yeah there's nothing
looking at us it only did that about
three or four times stop it dude i only
did that one for like
three or four times yeah i don't i don't
want some weird blue mist ball like
watching me when i'm like
in the back it was weird because it like
it didn't look like a three-dimensional
object that was there in space it looked
like an illusion like you had it looked
just like you had stared at the sun too
long
yeah but you know you see that like that
yeah and you see like that left over
that left over
the thing is normally that thing's
jumping all over the room because it's
on your eyeball it's on your eyeballs
this one is just like stuck there okay
you're stuck there
that's a good description that's what
it's like yeah i can picture that
and then when you try to focus your eyes
directly on it to see it it would it's
like
it would fade away like you you know
what i mean
like for some reason your your eye
wasn't able to [ __ ] see
that but maybe more in your peripheral
vision was a little bit easier
yeah like there wasn't enough available
light or something you know what i mean
or the image wasn't really there all the
way in this dimension it was something
slightly in another dimension i guess
that's the only way he was just popping
out of another dimension just but hey
i'm just like popping into this
dimension just check and see what's
going on in here i think that was just
the
i think there was just a manifestation
of of
of of it you know maybe that's just the
way your brain was interpreting it
you know what i'm saying maybe that's
just where it was touching
yeah maybe that's just where it was
touching three-dimensional space
yeah yeah and it was just a
a point of of perception in other words
it was like a point of view
yeah yeah i mean there wasn't anything
there other than that's what it was
seeing from
and you know it's kind of like an
out-of-body experience except it was
your subconscious that was out of body
oracle said i had a paranormal
experience it included an organ playing
itself while all the lights were on
that's pretty creepy yeah i don't
if i was sitting in this house by myself
and like heard some [ __ ] music coming
from somewhere
i'd probably shave my pants yeah did it
have a
it wasn't one of those uh player pianos
was it does anybody even have a player
piano anymore do young people even know
what a player piano is
i think all the people that thought
about player pianos are dead
well i'm still thinking about them like
you know not all the time but i know
what they are
she said he said it was a recital hall
at my school
yeah that's crazy yeah but yeah we'll
let you guys know if we have any more
paranormal activity happen
like i said i'm gonna be really upset if
this [ __ ] tv just keeps popping on
now you keep reminding me about it don't
worry about it i know now that we can't
now
the more i talk about it the more likely
it is to happen because i think that's
why it started happening before because
we said something
yeah and the more you the more you feed
into it the more the
the uh the phenomena starts to ramp up
because it's kind of like uh
you get your confidence built back up
yeah
well that's why it started back up again
after all that time because we were
writing the book about it so we were
talking about it all the time
and you kept getting reminded so then it
started here
yeah there's got to be like an element
of faith
that mor you know belief in it and faith
that it is
that it can still do its thing feeds it
more into the phenomenon it gets it it
would rapidly get stronger but i don't
know how strong it would get
i don't think it would get as strong as
i was when i was 13.
yeah you know not like like i said not
like scanners where you could throw
someone's head up i don't think
i'm not sure exactly what the phenomena
would look like i mean it's looking like
it did it's just not as recurrent yeah
it just happens every now and then and
it's like minor stuff
yeah it's a lot smaller just doors
opening back when that [ __ ] was really
rolling
okay when it was really rolling what
you've seen so far in this house
you wouldn't have even noticed that
right compared
to the up to the better phenomena
like an object just being thrown into
the room from another room
you know i mean nobody there to throw it
yeah you know well yeah like just a tv
coming up by itself a few times would
probably wouldn't even register yeah
because you're just like yeah well we
got all this other [ __ ] mammoth the tv
with the tv would be on and we'd notice
the [ __ ] image would get all
distorted and you'd look
and you back in the day back in the days
they had these little dials that you
turned yeah
and like the bottom one quarter of them
the bottom half of them
would be showing through the bottom of
this yeah you know that you could roll
like the brightness
the brightness and the [ __ ] vertical
and the horizontal and [ __ ]
you look down there and you'd see like
one or two of them moving slowly
yeah yeah that was some [ __ ] creepy
[ __ ]
red went up there [ __ ] i moved i saw
it
it's [ __ ] with the tv yeah the image
was getting weird
it's weird you'd see it moving but it
didn't seem to be affecting the
the screen to the same rate you know
because you could move that [ __ ]
the small amount and get a big effect
yeah it looked like it was moving quite
far but not changing the screen that
much
so it was affecting electronic uh you
know yeah
it affected that that's how i remembered
it though it was a long time ago
maybe it didn't move that much weird
yeah but yeah matter of fact we i we
didn't
did we even put that in the book i don't
remember you telling me that before so i
don't remember if i put that in the book
right it was only like one or two times
yeah i had forgotten all about the
matchbox cars
so that's what i did yeah i did put that
in there because you remembered it in
time because remember you were talking
to red on the phone yeah red was the one
that reminded me and he said something
about it
i talked to we talked to them on the
phone a lot before we wrote it because
they remembered stuff that you didn't
remember and vice versa
yeah red's dead he's dead now and it's
too bad because he would remember all
kinds of [ __ ] that i'd forgotten yeah he
died a couple of years ago
yeah that's kind of it yep uh
all right so we're gonna wrap it up like
i said we'll tell you guys
because we'll stream again tomorrow at
three probably do another movie review
or a side tracks or something we'll let
you know if we had any more
poltergeist activity at the house oh
pookie doesn't get all scared about it
i don't think she noticed anything she
probably didn't she was just like oh the
tv is on because it's always on
you see what we could do if it keeps
doing it
somehow put a camera on it while we're
asleep
yeah because ken asked earlier if we had
got anything ever on video but we never
have i don't think have you
seen house how it does it yeah it's like
no one's ever no one's ever filming
anything
yeah how could you catch that you know
you couldn't catch it
even back even back when i was 13
if you were to give me a modern like
this this modern [ __ ] tablet yeah i'd
have a hard time catching some of that
stuff it was so fast
yeah because you're not really expecting
it you're right you know
and it was almost kind of like the
objects that moved
it was moving the ones you weren't it
removed the objects you weren't directly
looking
at a lot of the time just like when that
remote flew off that table in front of
ever all four of us sitting there yeah
nobody was actually looking at the road
nobody was looking at it
like i was looking over it yeah over it
but they weren't looking at it it was
under my line of sight yeah no one was
looking right at it no
yeah it was weird it just i just saw it
in mid-flight
yeah i didn't see it actually come up
off the coffee table and that's the
and it's and it was always like that
yeah
the closest thing i saw of anything
actually
starting to move is when i was backing
out of that room and i was looking at
that big pen
sitting on that table and i was looking
right at it
but then the next thing i know i just
saw it halfway across the room flying
towards me so i must have blinked
yeah and which makes me think there's no
way it could have had the sense of
timing to go
when that [ __ ] blinks i'm gonna
move it
i don't think that's what's going on i
think that it can't move it
you know what i mean yeah until you're
not looking at it
it's now free to move it has something
to do with
perception you know i mean who's
perceiving it
are you perceiving it or is it
perceiving it if you're perceiving it
you're confirming its location in its
place you know it's place in space so
maybe it's like
too heavy it can't interact with it but
as soon as you're not looking at it it's
in kind of a neutral zone
of where it may be in several places and
once
once you're not looking at it it's now
it's now on the same all the
potentialities yeah it's in the same
dimension that it's in
so you know what i mean so then it can
move it
it's usually you see it in in in flight
or arriving yeah from somewhere else and
that's how it was with the remote
it's like basically because it was only
like a foot or two under my line of
sight so i didn't see it come off the
table i just saw it like when it was
already flying
yeah and then saw it hit the but it's a
weird phenomenon that people don't
believe exists it does exist eventually
they'll figure it out
it probably playing with technology
somehow
yeah i wonder some ufo [ __ ] ufo [ __ ]
yeah that's how they're getting here
that's how they're getting here
[Laughter]
we're gonna wrap it up we'll see you
guys again
tomorrow at 3 p.m est just like always
probably like i said do another review
or a
movie or a side tracks or whatever so
we'll see you guys
next time bye